if your job is to win hearts and Minds I
don't think this is the best way of
doing it you say that we can't win
hearts and Minds by being nice you don't
convince people by being nice at least
not on a cultural level I mean where did
you get this idea where did you arrive
at this conclusion that the way to win
the culture is by being nice is that how
the left won the culture have you been
paying attention at all they have seized
hold of our society indoctrinating
entire generations and they didn't do it
with niceness they did it by being bold
and aggressive and by making their
oppositions arguments seem not only
wrong but utterly horrific and insane
that's how they did it